welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host heisham azuz and
in this week's episode i was joined by
eden mark and jody who are all the
founders of a new recruitment company
called peratus partners
i absolutely loved this episode and it
was slightly different so eden jody and
mark have all been on a journey in the
last year of building their first
recruitment company so in this episode
we really deep dived into their first
year the challenges what tech do they
invest in how do they approach the
market how do they approach being
different and everything else in between
enjoy the episode eden jody mark welcome
to the podcast thanks for having us
uh this is new obviously we've got three
three of you guys with me today as i was
just saying
uh we did a bit of prep so we don't
shout over each other but one i'm really
excited for this and jody was your idea
i thought it was edens but uh obviously
a lot of people think about starting
their own recruitment business maybe uh
too worried about taking the leap some
people take the leap and it doesn't work
out uh but it can be really challenging
so obviously you guys are coming up to
your first year milestone so in this
episode in this conversation we're just
going to have a real deep dive in the
first year in business and what we've
learned challenges maybe what we'll do
differently to rewind the clock and uh
yeah just have a deep dive into that so
where i always like to start and jody
i'm going to come to you first is i
would just love to get your guys
perspective on what you believe makes up
a sort of highly successful recruitment
consultant in today's market if it's
characteristics traits what are some of
the things that you believe make up a
successful consultant
yeah i mean i think
generally like the things like
consistency i think consistency is
probably the main one um with
accountability there's a ton of traits
that you can look for but
generally i think what a important part
of it is actually the match because you
sometimes see recruiters do
terrible in one company move on and do
you know really really hit the ground
running so i think it's about the person
that they're working with and being
trained with as well i think that plays
a key role in
how successful someone can be so
um yeah having the same kind of not
necessarily the same personality but
um
definitely the same kind of like values
as them that's actually really
interesting eden what would you add to
that what are some of the things that
you think about when we think of
characteristics and traits i think we
touched on this before is the growth
mindset aspect i know a lot of people
who watch this you know say that but i'm
gonna have to follow suit but someone
who's constantly just trying to push
themselves learn and understand and kind
of be just a sponge of knowledge
that like it doesn't matter what level
you get to you always have something to
learn so obviously just echoing what
you've said if you've got someone who's
right for you to learn from and you want
to learn with them then i think that's
probably one of the biggest things i
would i'd say
mark anything to add i know it's
probably all being said but anything to
add to be fair
i've been asked this question so many
times but i think um
somebody just takes responsibility for
their their own actions i think for me
that's probably the most important thing
because you can
own it know where you've gone wrong and
start again um and just you know
take it on board and improve and move
forward really so i think that's one of
the traits that i'd always you know look
for
so let's unpack this first year then
obviously i've got a couple of questions
that we want to go into i guess
obviously where i wanted to start i'm
jody i'm going to come to you on this
first
is like obviously when a lot of people
start their own recruitment business i
think the most common sentence will be
like
we're going to do things differently
right so you've all worked for a few
different brands in different
environments so i guess first question
i'd love to get your perspective on jody
is like after working in the different
environments different companies with
different people
how did you guys approach being
different that could be internally
externally but when we think about you
guys building a recruitment business
that is different and you really
delivering on that what comes up for you
and what was the thought process
yeah
i think this is hard because there's so
much competition out there
um externally i think the
the main thing and it's probably a
change in my career from starting out
and then
becoming successful as a recruiter was
probably
actually listening to what the problem
was it's kind of standard sales really
listening to what challenges are out
there and responding to that and then
recognizing is it something i can
actually help with or do i just want to
pick up a job because i need the kpi
um so for us what the the angle or the
the way that we approach external um as
in picking up business is by
understanding what challenges people are
facing and that can change
certainly changed even between the gap
where
we say left recruitment but we had a
period of time where we couldn't uh work
or we just had a
gardening lead for example so um yeah we
kind of see different challenges from
that perspective of what clients were
facing and then how we respond to that
and what sell back we we kind of give
them um from an internal perspective i
think we've
we've kind of seen what we personally
feel or what i personally feel
worked well and made me feel valuable
valued as a recruiter
and also what doesn't um and i think
that's something that we want to do
correctly and also going forward having
like a feedback loop as we grow um
because you know as i say things going
to change all the time so getting
people's perspective um
and hearing from them as opposed to
being top down i think that's one of the
the main things well some of the things
just on that quickly because i think
when you're in the thick of like
building your own recruitment company
i think you can end up being the
employer that you didn't want to become
quite easily you know what i mean it's
like when you hear like you obviously
say a lot i never want to be like my mom
and then you're like [ __ ] i'm actually
like my mom do you know what i mean so
like just obviously we're not trying to
like name people or anything like that
but like what what are some of the
things that you experienced and maybe
made you feel like disgruntled didn't
feel valued i'd just be interested to
hear some of that because sometimes i
think these things can be missed so what
what are some of the things you
experienced that looking back you know
what that if they maybe changed that or
didn't do those things i could have
probably been even more engaged with
work what are some of the things that
made you didn't feel valued so moving
milestones i guess is one um moving the
goalpost yeah yeah i think that's that's
one i think
you know there needs to be balance and
people need to be clear on what
expectations are before you you you know
start and also having consistency in
that because
i've had several managers and and it
sort of changes and that plays a part in
it i guess i think it's the the
awareness of the
high performing team around you okay i
think that plays a big part in in that
side you know having people that want to
genuinely push each other and then you
know are able to support each other and
not put each other down right yeah
aspect so actually like all rise
together all yeah we like celebrate each
other's wins across the whole company
not just your specific team but across
the whole business and i think the fact
that we're mindful of that you know
automatic obviously how we've been
trying to be different in total because
we've been in that environment before
and we're mindful of it just having that
that conscious awareness that okay as we
grow or even with the the team we have
now
let's try to avoid that as much as we
can okay
so let's just frame this up for people
then so eden what were the
what were like when you when you guys
first thought about first year in
business
what were the major milestones or goals
because i know we can talk about how
they've changed and maybe sort of
underplayed what you could achieve but
just talk us through what the initial
goals were and then we'll just talk a
bit about um where hopefully you're
looking to end up and what you're on
track to do and then we'll unpack
well this is going to go against what
joey said about changing goal posts yeah
we did so i think we we were kind of
always told especially at the beginning
like don't expect too much you know
don't don't worry about you know if
you're not making money just like
basically do the bare minimum just to
get by essentially that's
going with that mentality which would
all kind of go a bit you know a bit
weird about but we kind of was very
reserved on on what our targets would be
um which we blew out quite quickly and
obviously adjusted but i think it was
that first year
going into a new market with no branding
behind you
going into you know we couldn't go back
to old clients for a period of time so
we had to be a bit more savvy in what
we're doing and i think for us it was
just
fine we need to keep the lights on and
we had to pay our bills that was your
favorite phrase for about two months
i think it's just about having you know
for us it was just about making sure we
get to the end of the first year
with a decent enough client base that we
can look and start building and
expanding yeah because we have all these
audacious goals and ideas but when you
have nothing in the bank really at the
beginning and you just have an idea you
need money behind you and capital behind
you to make those ideas come forward so
i think that first year for us was about
us three getting settled in you know we
we're in a
position we've hired people and now we
can start the second year with enough
money in the bank to actually really
look forward and start growing properly
so let's just get those goals down what
are the billing goals so when you first
write it down the very first one i think
so we went on correctly from wrong it
was 300 nfi right yeah so that was
money in the bank yeah so
what we're on now is
i think you guys have the last numbers
yeah we're close to our target
close to our new target
what's the only target a million okay
profit profit yeah so we're we're 11
we've got 10 months 10 months we've got
six weeks to go six weeks ago so we
should hopefully but your initial target
was 300 yeah getting close to a million
okay cool what about did you have any
head count goals in your original plan
was just like e3 yeah it's just us three
okay and you've got a person one another
person so we've got two now we've got um
our first high was in january because
she was um she's asked business support
officer she doesn't do recruitment she
does yeah everything else that we would
need need from someone sure um and our
first recruitment delivery partner came
on in april i believe
um and yes she's and then what about did
you have any like or you said obviously
yeah trying to obviously build enough of
a client base that you can then expand
on second year what were the the initial
client goals did you have like signed
terms with x number of clients in the
first year did you have you guys around
that i don't think we kind of went as as
deep as i think because we're all quite
aware of our ability to recruit yeah i
think getting stuck into very specifics
at the very beginning saying okay mark
you need to do 10 client sign-ons we had
we had discussion about how we're going
to do each month
yeah it never really kind of stuck
because it's you do get stuck in the job
yeah but also having those goals kind of
then it becomes a goal for a sake of a
goal and you have too many goals going
on you kind of just lose your way so i
think it was just keep it as simple as
possible that's the money yeah how we
make it how we get there yes you just
had the monetary goals yeah okay as mark
would say if we can't do that it might
as well give up
yeah nice okay cool love that thanks for
sharing that so i guess eden if i come
back to you then really quickly so
thinking again thinking about the
beginning like what was like you said
couldn't go to some of the um clients
that you worked with in the past
like what was the go to market strategy
like just talk us through a bit what was
the game plan what was the approach to
take people from having no [ __ ] clue
about your company
not just being seen as another
recruitment company like talk talk us
through like the go-to-market strategy
what that looked like yeah so i had to
do it for the first three months by
myself um which was tough i think having
a conversation with these two they could
see it wasn't an easy ride for me
because everything's on your shoulders
you know the clock's ticking until you
get money in the bank the clock is
ticking so
because we couldn't go back to old
clients we couldn't leverage
relationships
um i basically thought back what made me
successful
pre-leaving the former company but even
before that because when i left i had
repeat clients i had good relationships
it's gone all the way back to the
beginning that first first year or two
of recruitment what made me successful
then and then kind of going back to the
very very basics and for us for me it
was really about
what do the clients truly want they want
quality-led approach so just give them
exactly what they're asking for in the
job descriptions online and try and
build those connections that way so
don't get fancy you don't have to
do all the marketing and stuff things
like that because you know we didn't
have the time for it it was just very
clear put the right product in front of
them make it compelling enough start the
conversation and then back to what
joey's saying was was all conscious from
the beginning having that awareness of
if we're right for you it will work if
we're not the right agency because of x
y and z it's not going to so then going
into the next three months because when
they could join i think we all sat down
and realized
what what if you could go back i myself
to the beginning knowing now what you
know what would you do and that's when
we introduced our client matrix okay so
we we sat down so when these two could
could basically hopefully hit the ground
running straight away as well sat down
worked out
list of criteria 15 things this is what
makes a perfect client and we graded
them and it basically spews out you know
whether or not we should work with that
customer or not and we're quite honest
with the clients we'll sit with them on
a briefing call and say look
you're you're ranked very low you know
realistically for you for us to engage
with you
we need to see this percentage or we
need to see this money amount money up
front so we're very upfront with them
you know some clients like it some don't
but that's an awareness again you know
from the beginning that we're a
partnership between client and us and if
they don't want that level of
partnership then we're not the right
agency for them and it also means we
just don't work you know as
many roles but they're better qualified
also it's not to say that you know
everyone needs to to score high it can
be there's factors in there that's like
these are maybe they're what we would
call a b client but essentially we're
then working on the areas to make them
an a client so if their process is
really long that's something we can then
consult them on and advise them on why
and what the the comparisons are using
data to back it up to say this is
ex-clients are making this amount of
fires in this time frame you're not and
we believe it's because of this so it's
kind of like a way of us recognizing
what we need to consult on as well it's
not to say that if you're not hitting
the mark we won't work with you yes it's
not fixed yeah there is fluidity to it
no i love that and then mark would you
mind sharing some of those because i
think that'll be really useful for
people because i think
obviously as you learn early on right
you're talking about those at those
early times like what you're really good
at early on is like working on [ __ ] jobs
basically and just say wasting your time
but you know what i mean so obviously
what you've done really well there is
you're trying to obviously only work and
put your time in which is the most
valuable thing that you have in
especially those early days you're
trying to get to that first placement
these things that you're working with
committed clients that you know that if
you do get the right people in front of
them that there's a good chance it's
going to be a smooth process
and it's going to be a partnership you
said so i think this would be helpful
for people so mark let me ask you then
because i love that point there what you
said it's not it's not just for us it's
like hey look this is where you're at
but these are some of the things that we
can maybe help you improve on so we
could actually have an even better
partnership but what are some of the
other facts important factors mark on
that because i think that'd be really
helpful for people on their client
matrix things that you look for um
yeah there's a few things like in terms
of like commitment i think a lot of the
the scoring is all to do with commitment
from both ends you know how many
agencies
um do we have signed terms uh interview
process how long does it take to
uh interview um even to like salary
expectations so i think they're all
based on
giving you know initial feedback to say
one can we add value yeah if the
salaries are too low for the market then
why should we take it on we can't you
know there's no point taking on a role
if we can't place it i think that's the
that was the common trend
throughout and
everything come back to time as well you
know we would always
we'll always say to any client you know
we'll only take you your project on or
the client on if we can uh actually
actually believe that we can we can live
and we can place it yeah okay so back to
the beginning then eden because he was
on your own for a bit what was the
thought process behind tech stack talk
us through that
my faith in my life
here talk us through like what was the
initial thought process of life this is
what we need as a minimum yeah to get
going because i think you can get quite
lost in this can't you yeah there's
always new shiny things i'm the most
tech savvy and we think i've lost it
whenever we've spoken yeah
i'm tech savvy but i'm not that's the
that's really so it's like the blind
leading the blind on this one okay so
crm system telephone system and website
that's what you wanted that was easy as
anything we kind of all had a very clear
idea what we wanted found a couple of
partners trialed them and it was very
very quick but it was the actual systems
that we used internally because
obviously we set up different times so i
got a laptop i got i then you obviously
bought microsoft word and all that stuff
but i bought my personal account right
and then these two did the exact same
thing and then trying to merge personal
accounts to business accounts and then
trying to get us all on to a share drive
was just a headache but we didn't also
explore um google cloud which i know you
use for a period of time um so we didn't
explore different areas we kind of just
went to what we knew
and what you've used previously yeah and
going looking back now
and it might even still be an option i
might revert
to a different system like google cloud
for example but for now we're set up
with microsoft but
there's good and bad for both but
needs to have a shared driving obviously
if we have more more than one person but
the telephones the crm system and and
the website was like minimum yeah and
obviously linkedin have one but that
takes like two days to get set up yeah
and like what what did you like did you
try and really negotiate cheap deals or
anything like i don't know what was the
how much budget do you think that that's
going to be a conversation really
yeah joey was
was very good at saving
queen suppliers
because people listen to this can try
and get better deals end of the month
contacting them at the end of the month
we're the same you know still to be
closed um
[Music]
getting comparisons and yeah i guess
just just
going backwards and forwards with him a
few times spending that little bit of
extra time and not not taking the first
very persistent let him sweat a little
bit not just taking the first one and
letting them realize oh [ __ ] they might
go somewhere else
that helped but the end of the month
helped massively especially with our
telephone system so on just on the
subject i get a lot of messages from
sort of early stage founders what what
was the approach on terms
did that so or like just like i get a
lot of messages saying like do you have
any like term templates and stuff like
that because i think sometimes that
can't really confuse people so your
actual terms of business how do you get
that sorted well we're quite lucky
because we have quite a lot of friends
in different companies that founded
their own businesses i think we used
what we knew in general especially we
both said both all three of us had an
awareness of what time should look like
yeah and then working with what we kind
of knew with what other people showed us
and then speaking to obviously actual
legal advice about so you did get some
really good advice yeah yeah i think we
took especially for you like especially
the contracts interims they was like
quite complex especially the compliance
and things like that so there was hours
and hours of
of work and proofreading and i was
probably the worst person to proofread
because really
joey used to go mark have you read it
yet i'm like yeah i'll do it tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow have you read it yet
and i'll see like 32 pages on that oh
wow i i need to push it back to another
week but that took a lot of time and
effort and actually going through
to make sure we was i think as well with
like um
like coming from contracts recruitment
you're always getting frameworks to be
reviewed from from client framework so
having that kind of understanding helps
then
you know
i think that maybe you know if other
recruiters are looking at doing their
own thing um
that would help if they're reviewing
client terms themselves rather than
passing that over to their their manager
right right there to get that exposure
because you know roughly what sort of
terms should go in there it's just a
word in how do you put it into a legally
buying contract we don't screw yourself
over that's obviously what we needed the
advice for but the the standard things
that just put yourself in the mind of
what would a client want to know and
also because we're reviewing contracts
of other companies as suppliers to us
again it's a very similar thing you just
have to write it back to yourself i
think we was quite well equipped on like
the permanent side like leading like the
teams um over the last like six years
like you've you've reviewed so many
contracts and so many questions and
queries have come up you sort of you see
it every word is slightly different and
you sort of understand what it means and
why it's in there i think that was quite
key but the contract side was definitely
a lot more complex
so i'd get some advice on that if
if anyone's asking the difficult one i
think it was actually the internal
employee contract
that was quite common yeah because
obviously we've never had to do that
because when you hire someone in a
previous company just send the contract
out you don't pay attention to it so
then it's like putting a mindset in okay
what do we want to put into that
contract for us as an employer
yeah and precisely yeah so that one was
a was a little bit take a bit of time
yeah and we didn't really give ourselves
too much time to really do it because
the person could start quite quickly and
just all of a sudden yeah okay
on this then what i also want to ask uh
i don't know who'd be the best person to
ask but what about i also get a lot of
messages around like i think what
sometimes people don't realize i've had
some of these conversations where like
when you're an employee
you close a deal and you write on the
board banglagong whatever and you're
like yep i know what commission i'm
getting deal done
when you're a business owner that means
[ __ ] all
these invoices are gonna get paid before
so like i've spoke to so many people
where like
yeah like obviously they've got invoices
out then they're not getting paid until
60 days or other like that's that can be
really difficult what's been your
journey with that
good yeah you've had people paying on
time is that on your matrix
difficulty on the matrix because you
don't know they could say yeah of course
we will but you know terms is on there i
think yeah payment dates so i think it's
like if they pay within 14 days an
invoice on um signed that's the one
really so i think we've only got two
clients so far that we raise on when the
candidate starts which is a big deal for
us because most of our candidates start
three months after we have yeah so
you've got ten oh so you so you invoice
on a contract yeah
i think it's if you're confident going
into it like if you sound like you don't
really know what you're talking about
you shouldn't be asking this question
they'll always come back but if you're
stern it's like it's one of those one of
the questions obviously non-negotiable
that sort of stuff of course we can for
the right client discuss it but mostly
it's
it's and then what what's like the
agreement if then like they accept a
camera offer or it doesn't go through
they're just full refund yeah yeah
yeah won't keep the money if we don't
you know it's nice so you haven't i
think sometimes spoke to a lot of early
stage founders where like obviously
amongst all the other stuff they found
themselves just chasing footload of
invoices and all that and that's just
really stressful yeah
we haven't had that and
process of we have an invoice invoice
tracker
we do a deal we put the information on
they send me a candy invite and as soon
as that date comes as long as i'm pretty
much aware of it and we just chase that
day and make sure i think we're
transitioning that because we're getting
more contracts and interims coming in
and the invoices are getting
more of them essentially we're getting
um vicky to to really take range of that
and make sure we're on top of
getting paid um but we're actually
that's how we're gonna yeah
yeah so how long again just i guess to
the beginning part then how long did it
take to do your first deal
just under two months okay um but we
should have done one sooner so really so
two i've just under two hours to
actually get one sorted but prior to
that we had two offers that accepted
counter offers which um that was a real
tough pill to swallow because
pre-closing but they count the other
companies coming with just stupid
counteroffers there's nothing we could
do and then one where they kind of
accepted but then the company closed
so in in the two months we had four
opportunities
again so the company made an offer he
accepted and then two a week later they
basically shut the doors and said we're
firing everyone oh wow yeah so that was
a
again nothing we could do but i think at
that point because i'm sitting there
stressed beyond belief thinking i need
to make it do i need to make a deal yeah
i think it was like you two sit me down
going well you're clearly doing
something right yeah it's working just
keep plugging away like we're getting
back to it because you're getting there
just through like it just didn't happen
i think just on that really quickly i
think will be really helpful people i'm
always curious like
when you are when you are in those
moments or on that journey what are the
things that you're like keeping a close
eye on that gives you confidence that
you're doing the right things because i
think that that can be quite hard to see
isn't it because you you want to get the
end result of that placement and get
that first milestone yeah but what are
the things you keeping top of mind daily
weekly that you're like right if i keep
doing this
then i feel confident that i know it's
going to pay off and i'm doing the right
thing
i think
i'm quite big on feedback loops and
obviously i think as a business we'll be
that way inclined we do with our clients
all the time so i don't think there's
one particular activity or thing i think
it's constantly having awareness of the
client this is what we're doing and
being very transparent this is what
we've done for you so far do you need us
to pivot the search do we need to change
something as long as the feedback is
coming in from them as you know the
candidates are good like keep going all
the you know
when we're sending um
candidates to jobs they're happy as well
i think that's the biggest indicator
that we're on the right tracks um i
don't think there's a specific activity
to say okay you're doing it other than
does that kind of get that job or do
they move through that process
and just being you know i think we also
like um every monday wednesday and
friday we'll have like a
meeting just between all of us um to
kind of highlight what's going on on our
desk and what what's going right what's
got even outside of our destiny fair um
but it's kind of a chance for us to call
each other out and just see like well
have you done this have you done that
have you checked yeah
yeah even though we've we've all done it
for a while it's very easy to um
yeah i guess get get stuck into it
without actually yeah making sure that
you've done every step so it's kind of
um i think that's probably a key part as
well having having sounds soppy but
having each other yeah yeah i was gonna
that wasn't my next thing like when
because we were just speaking a bit
about when you was on your own for the
first part
and i know i asked you this before but
i'm always curious like how
how did you guys maybe mark you can
start this off but like when obviously
it was then free of you like what what
was we doing or what did we did you
quick did you guys quickly learn what
you was all better at at certain things
beyond like billing and beyond being a
recruiter how did you work that out
so we actually we actually worked that
out by a complete saying what do you
think you'd be good at before we even
just asked in the direction yeah and we
broke it down into marketing hr and and
finance people okay there were three hr
and we thought there are three parts
that we we need someone to just take
reins off yeah did we know he was good
at it no we just say right aidan when i
do marketing and i said okay i'll do
finance and judge that dirty gossip
so really yeah so really we we didn't
know who was stronger at what and i
think we've been learning
like this not to say like i'm the best
at finance because i jody helps me aiden
helps me yeah joey market
that's my responsibility yeah if it goes
wrong like for example pension schemes
at the moment or last month has been
like the pain in my life really trying
to work out how to create pension
schemes and just learn and listen to
videos but
that's my responsibility and my stress
marketing has been his stress contract
hr stuff has been judged stressed so
we're still not at that point where i
don't think we go right that is yeah
that you've all had on this conversation
of like right this is maybe what i'm
good at and then as you said it's then
being willing to hold each other
accountable yeah rather than i think i
spoke to a lot of people where maybe
they didn't have that honest
conversation and you're all trying to do
a bit of marketing hr finance stepping
each other's toes and then that's when
it can get difficult confusing like i
know for a fact with like the marketing
stuff i'm definitely not especially sad
at it and i'll always take on on their
opinions but same thing with mark like
when we're never going to be
a cmo or a cfo yeah or it's not it's not
it's not it's not perfect it's just
if it works let's not just let's just go
with it for a moment and we're tweaking
stuff all the time that's the thing like
the finance stuff like the invoice
trackers where what we started with and
what we've got now is is slightly
different and long as it's not broken so
far then we we're sticking with it and
just taking on
little tweaks and advice from each other
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your grown recruitment business with
sauce breaker if you want to make sure
that all of your recruiters have the
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out sourcebreaker use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products okay so i want to definitely
touch on like
uh how you approach hiring internally
and what that was like but really
quickly i want to ask all of you i
definitely we've kept it quite positive
so far one and definitely get some of
these challenges right but like what do
we
and feel free any of you to like sort of
start but like obviously we've said
about your goals initially and what
you're on track to do
like i know them obviously i want to
give you guys as much credit as possible
obviously the market's crazy right in
terms of everyone saying how well
they're doing all these things but like
what do we think of some of the
principles things that you've done
fundamentals that you've done that
really enabled you guys to build
traction and like really over exceed
initial expectations of yourself like
what are some of the things you guys
think you've done really well to build
traction
oh that's a hard one i'll start going
i think
i think for us i think
having the business
and because obviously our perspective of
recruitment is gonna be different for
someone who's employed now yeah every
deal matters so much more
and i think knowing that it allows us to
give a better service i think this is
the best recruitment i've personally
ever done not because there's loads of
opportunity there is but because i know
every single deal counts more so than
ever and taking a step back and thinking
okay
you know is it worth my time or is that
kind of truly going to take that job and
advising the client you want him or her
but they don't want you so that let's
just not waste our time let's just
go go separate ways with it and not just
putting kpis on for the sake of it but
making sure for a fact that everything
we're working is as close to either
we're filling it or the job's coming off
because the candidate but then the
company filled it internally and that's
it for me that's very interesting so
like there's just yeah you're right so
when it's become your own business
you've got an extra bit of pride so much
yeah because it's not a thousand pounds
in your back pocket per deal it's 15
grand yeah and you're sitting there
thinking okay like that's gonna hurt so
so much more if that needs to come off
and i think you know
crazy enough that he's like three heads
in one you know we have we go for walks
for like 45 minutes and all we're
talking about is how we can work out how
to close one's person's camera and we're
going to follow all these different
scenarios they might not even be true
but we're thinking what are they
thinking are they doing this and we're
all
yeah and to be honest it's attention to
detail for me working with these two as
a as a free we come up with a solution
at the end there's always a problem like
well they've got this or they've got
that and we just sit we just go for that
or a walk or a chat and then all of a
sudden we well i've got it and you go
back to the office and the person just
says yeah i'm accepted yeah well we're
done
45 minutes for no reason but at least
we've gone through the motion of
thinking okay what every time what could
go wrong in case it does and then we're
prepared for it as much as we can yeah
so i know i know we you said before but
you feel like you've really
uh been like really grateful that it's
all you feeling this journey isn't it
that's massively helpful so i guess joey
let me come to you first then what have
been some of your biggest challenges so
far
[Laughter]
you just come across arrogant
but
it's not that there's not been
challenges there's been things that we
didn't know but i've always felt that we
would be able to work it out um and we
we have it's it's actually
i think i maybe worked it up more in my
head i thought it was going to be harder
than it actually turned out yeah so yeah
i mean for anyone that is also i think
we were maybe in a position where we
were ready to do it like um for me
personally i sort of kind of
stopped learning
as much as i'd want to and
you're saying about the deals like the
deals would you'd be happy that they
happen but
the the numbness of someone not
accepting your offer just kind of yeah
you get used to it so um
i think for me i was kind of ready for a
new challenge um so i may be yeah i
think maybe i
sounds underplayed but i think anyone
that's in that position where they feel
like they needed something to to learn
again
just go for it because it's not as bad
as you kind of think
okay at least that's what i found so
what let me ask this in a different way
then this is one of the questions that i
got which i think is sometimes sometimes
often missed talking about work stuff
here what about somebody let me come to
you first on this what about
what has the stress of being in a
startup you guys wanting to achieve
putting pressure on yourself how's that
affected your personal relationships
um
it's funny expectations is like
once they started to gather pace
um that was probably the that was the
pressure on that's all you could think
about right so at the start where we had
minimal say right
all we got to do is keep the lights on
for example
there was no no pressure or no stress
and then once your expectations grow and
they keep growing we keep moving the
goal posts i think that pressure started
to
to mount and each meaning and jodie
don't feel the pressure as much as me
and even for some reason but we need an
early in in
in the month we start we're a bit we're
a bit edgy a bit flappy like oh we're
not gonna and then all of a sudden we
get to the middle of a month and just
laugh about in a week game it's
happening again we're getting to the
middle and we're starting to it's the
fortunate cycle of our of our months at
the moment yeah but i do try and break
work and although we speak all weekend
on a group chat about deals i do try and
switch off on a on a friday uh like
evening and then come back on sunday
sunday night although i do feel guilty i
said to these two in a week when i have
a couple of days off i feel that guilt
they're in the office i went to a
wedding last week come back and i was
like oh god i've let them down i've gone
away for a couple of days
i don't think i'm gonna get away from
that guilty feeling yet until i feel we
have
employees and people running our
business for us
alongside us i feel that pressure and
you know just letting them down not just
being in the office is there and then
and that's real so what about you what
about you then personal relationship so
you're soon to be a dad yeah that's
going to be a new new part of the
equation in your life yeah that's uh
timed perfectly
so
yeah how was the expectation stresses of
building this effect a differential your
personal relationship i'm really really
fortunate so my behalf does recruitment
oh wow so i'm super lucky she knows the
stress you know is the pressure of
checking your phone at nine o'clock at
night thinking why the hell's this kind
of not responding to me so i'm really
really lucky in the fact that i can talk
through some of the problems i'm having
and she also then can give me her
perspective um so it hasn't really had
too much
too much issues certainly i do feel
going into the next chapter of with
obviously birth my child that's going to
be different and that's
that's i have no idea how that's going
to handle because obviously she's going
to want me home more and i'm going to
because i also value being in the office
and i'm saying completely you saying
about feeling guilty yeah taking that
time off
that would have to be a question i have
to revisit because at the moment
personally for the last year it's i've
had no lower issues i've been able to
switch off when i wanted to and
so so when when did we know then let's
talk a bit about hiring then so
how one of the questions i got which i
think is really interesting one so if
you think about your initial goals you
didn't have any head head count goes on
there so one of the questions that i got
and obviously you've hired two people
now like how how do you know when you're
ready to hire another recruit to another
employee like i think people interested
in like the financials you think about
the runway that you give yourselves to
make sure you're not stressing or that
person's salary doesn't give a huge
stress on the business how did we
approach that but how did you sort of
know that or feel confident that you
could sustain a new employee in a a
salary for someone um i think with the
very first hire wasn't a recruiter um so
she's the business support officer
and i think with her it was quite easy
we already knew her um she wanted a
super flexible environment she's like
she's got children so she basically just
wanted a place where she can work
part-time but she doesn't want to
recruit yeah but she knew new
recruitment and it just that worked
perfectly in the sense of
the salary because it's only part-time
it wasn't a huge
factor for it um with the with obviously
our delivery partner i guess that's a
different story because obviously that
is a salary person with a commission
structure that we have to factor in i
think it's just being aware that
obviously we need obviously to be able
to pay her for a period of time to keep
the business afloat for a period of time
um i guess you guys focus on it yeah i
was going to say that i think we've been
my finances
like maybe like right three months i
don't know how do you think we actually
we
are i guess we're very cautious but jody
created a like a very particular budget
plan and i mean to a t where we went
through
everything is on this excel where we
know our ins and outs to a penny um but
it helped us just understand right we've
got
nine to twelve we actually trying to
have nine to twelve one runway at least
i'm like
human being i think we said before like
the
the pressure we don't have that pressure
now but when we started that pressure of
the runway yeah um if you have a too
short of a runway i think that will
disrupt that whole thing
we didn't want to bring someone on
knowing that we can't offer them a
long-term career you know one it's bad
you're ruining your whole reputation
bringing your first personal and then
going oh sorry we actually haven't got
enough money for the next couple of
months so we was very cautious i think
and i think in terms of how you think
about moving forward what's the runway
are you going to give yourself itself
same time period if you're getting a
delivery partner yeah i think it makes
more sense now is it two years we've got
yeah the runway yeah
yeah to keep the business just as we are
if we've got about two years two years
yeah i think moving moving to the next
priority in uh october let eden settle
in as a dad and then it's time to really
hopefully start scaling up yeah and that
is the plan of action right i guess but
that budget plan that you've created
that you actually answer the question
and you know plug the numbers in yeah it
will tell us yeah that factors in every
benefit that we would give that person
even dancing so you know exactly the
cost to the business yes yeah which is
sometimes you're missing commission
taxes and everything and it was really
on that then quickly i know he was going
to say something joey but the other
question i had and you can factor in
what we're talking about how did you
guys approach
commission approach commission
structures
how much did you weight to salary out of
interest because people were curious
because we've all experienced different
things right so how did i'll come to you
gentlemen how how did you guys approach
that in terms of the commission um
opportunity for the um your hires and
then also how much did you wait to the
salary
yes i mean aidan's probably better this
one because he created a um
like a framework of um essentially each
yeah each step like a progression plan
for every level that we we hire and
because we didn't we wanted to start the
business knowing that the people that we
bring in um we've got a future for them
because at the end of the day we don't
have um you know we don't have the the
holiday incentives at the moment we
don't have some of the benefits of
typical things yeah competitors can
offer so
what are they joining they're joining us
as people and
um a future a career with us so that was
something that um
yeah eden put together in terms of like
salary bandings we all kind of discussed
you know what we would see as a fair
salary in comparison um and then we
factored in percentages based on um yeah
like a commission structure that we was
used to but maybe tweaked it was tweaked
a bit um we also figured that from a 180
perspective it should be 50 50
which is different to what we so just 50
50 split with the
it's a candidate driven market more so
now um and it's you can't do one without
the other they're both very valid career
paths as well and i think the the career
fair we put together highlights that and
having that awareness 50 50 from the
very get-go
that you know it's not an environment
where the business development
consultant i've seen there's better as
yeah they just take pictures and that's
what i think that's really changing at
the moment i've had a lot of interesting
conversations on that of like i think
yeah like you're saying like a 360
recruitment consultant i've had the
perception that they weren't as good
mm-hmm sorry they were better than
better than but i think yeah i think
more and more
modern recruitment companies are
building delivery functions and delivery
teams and that needs to be seen as like
just as good of a career opportunity so
two very different skills like very very
different skills in aspects and i think
it's having that
that understanding that if you don't
want to do the business side you can
solve a career without a crew and having
that kind of get go this is what that
crew would look like this is what you
would need to achieve and then this is
the commission structures for both yeah
so a couple of things as we come to the
end here then so
like on that like just if you don't if
you don't mind sharing because i've had
a couple of questions about it i've
spoke to a lot of recruitment founders
who have actually been really surprised
by the
starting base salary
um on when hiring people i think it's
changed it's just massively changed
right obviously inflation and obviously
all these different things but i think
if you were to like when i started
recruitment i think i was on like an 18k
base and then like commission and i was
speaking to a guy the other day where
he's interviewing like entry-level
people grads or non-grads and there are
they're asking for like 25-28 grand as a
base and some people like [ __ ] how
like how we got to this point so would
you mind sharing like how when you said
salary bandings how did you think about
that that was fair or you guys are based
in essex aren't you yeah how do you
think about that
we um
we recruited into our last companies
anyways we had the kind of an idea of
what it would be speaking to those rec
directs um is it what the market is is
it's gonna be the best on the market
probably not
obviously you can always evaluate
we haven't really had the opportunity to
test it because yeah the the person that
we actually hired into delivery um
she worked at the cafe around the corner
yeah and it wasn't we didn't hire her
based on her recruitment experience she
hired her base on her culture she felt
we felt that she could be a good match
she was looking we were hiring and
that's like we didn't have to have to
test it yeah i found it too much i think
that's um
in terms of like salary expectation i
think that's something that we will
constantly look at i think one of the
things that robbie was frustrated about
before was
they didn't know what they didn't move
with the times i think for us we just
have to keep looking at the market and
you know what we know about nine months
ago when we created the progression plan
um might be different now so it's
something that yeah it's definitely
something we need to keep keep an eye on
um for sure yeah we tell our clients to
look at the data from the market and we
all do the same yeah where we haven't
had the chance to test it against the
market because we're not going to market
to find a recruiter
yeah
we might be well off we don't know i
also think that the kind of um
yeah the sellers you mentioned are
probably more grads in london yeah um
maybe chelmsford as well i guess but
that's not
yeah for us it's i think we pay fair for
for the area that we're we're in
essentially because we've got the travel
costs and that kind of thing so yeah so
okay cool so cub i want to make sure
obviously artists question them before
we
finish um
like i'll he didn't i'll come to you
first obviously people always interested
to know know what you know now what
would you do differently like if you
were to start this over so we'll go
right we'll go around and see what comes
up but like for you personally
from what you've learned what would you
do differently if we were to start this
journey again i know it's exceeded
expectations there's been challenges
it's gone well but what do you think
maybe you would do differently
breathe a bit more i'll just take a step
back
like um because there's periods of time
although like the months are going well
like there's still those moments of like
oh [ __ ] it's not gonna come crashing out
it's not like we're stable we're okay
you're okay and it took a long time to
realize that i still haven't realized it
fully yet so i think if i was gonna go
start from the very beginning i'll just
try and enjoy i mean i've loved it but
i'll try and enjoy it just a little bit
more oh yeah it's hard yeah because you
out of the month that you still get
those days where you just like you have
wobbles wake up
yeah i think just try and enjoy it as
much as you can because the lights are
still on
i think i don't know if you guys have
found this but on that like i personally
with my own journey i like for me i
listen to like constructive feedback and
where we can improve way more than like
positive feedback so if i have someone
say to me oh this is great like you've
created this blah blah blah but then
they say i'd be like have you i think
you could do this better or like have
you thought about this like when i then
remember that conversation that's way
more loud i remember that more than the
like good things that i've done so don't
like i've i'm terrible at like
patting myself on the back
i think that's because we have the three
of us and yeah if it was those those
first three months were awful because
although they were there saying you're
doing okay you're doing good like i
could only share my own success whereas
now it's the three of us i'm having a
[ __ ] day these two are smashing it i
feed off and bring it up and it brings
you back up the next day yeah having
that dynamic it's a lot more um but i'm
filming the exact same i always take the
the negative or the like the construct
things yeah you're always looking at
working yeah i think that's it i don't
think that's a bad thing now i i believe
the good things look after themselves
and then the bad things you need to take
note of yeah so i always believe in that
anyway um so what would you make and
what comes up for you mark on maybe
approach things differently or looking
back on this journey um
i've probably spoke to a few more people
um before i started um you know i knew
about recruitment i know about how to do
a process and have to do everything
pretty much more about that business
side you know we were speaking to my
auntie owns a uh
agency but i would have spoke to a lot
more people in the market be a bit more
out there finding out what the problem
challenge challenges i feel like we've
done a lot of surface level maybe done a
bit more
homework on the
finance side how to you know set up
people on paye uh instead of waiting
until the problem come and then then
doing it so yeah i would have done a
little bit although we've done a lot of
homework research meetings like towards
building a business it was more that
stuff that i wasn't aware of
self-education yeah yeah
if i did it again i would have invested
that four months a bit more yeah uh into
speaking to more people and i think just
on that i've definitely experienced it i
don't know if you have but like you'd be
surprised how many people willing to
help yeah when you're asked as long as
especially if you speak to other
business owners because they've been in
your shoes um jody what about you what
comes up for you anything that you do
differently maybe
probably you'll get the same technology
and furniture we're a typical start-up
in that sense um so i think now that's
something that's probably going to cost
us going into future years when we start
to um yeah make everything the same
um
and also maybe look at more automation
tools um
i know there's an expense to that as
well but i think that's something that
can actually save your time
um i mean one of the best things i think
we've done was was bringing on vicky
which has helped take away some of the
like administrative tasks which has
allowed us to do more selling and i
think that's maybe another way that we
could have done that or at least
researched about it to do um
yeah i think they're probably the two
two things that i would be looking at
now for the next
i love that so let's just go around one
last time then and we'll finish there
but back to you then jody what like
people listening that are considering
taking the leap maybe being on a similar
journey to you before you started this
business has got a good um amount of
experience maybe worked a few different
companies
always like the idea of starting their
own but maybe as you said like really
maybe play out too much like all this
stuff they don't know like the hr
finance marketing that could mean that
they weren't capable what would be
advice for those people considering
taking the leap
just do it just go for it i think um
yeah i've seen obviously some people do
set up and think you know
it's boring on my own or i've not got
the same passion it's not the same when
you're doing a deal and i think maybe
like yeah somebody not just anybody
that's doing well in the company but
somebody that you actually trust um
partner with them and do it just go for
it because i think you can you can learn
along the way as long as you're still
open to learn and don't think you know
you kind of know it all right um yeah
just go for it really i think for me
like news was saying i don't
really get stressed but i'm quite
stubborn so
my head won't be stressed but my bod
like i'll have like i'll feel like
stomach problems and things like that so
i get it in a kind of different way so
um yeah i think just maybe
take a step back when you when you think
you
you're not capable and revisit it and go
again it's it's like anything you've
just got to be consistent with it so
what about you um
yeah i think the biggest advice is are
you ready to own your own business like
if you asked me five years ago
i wasn't ready i i could do the job but
i wasn't ready on a personal level so i
think being ready being financially
stable
um is probably the two main points and
then the rest you can do the job if
you're just working for a different
brand that's not the problem it's more
the fact are you ready to take on
that whole responsibility and are you
ready in in your personal life for
example to take it on
aidan
i mean i think they both said it all but
just do it if you if you've got that
that thought process in your head that i
might want to do it i think i could do
it you're never ever going to work the
same again because that's always going
to be in your head even if you stay at
the same company for another six months
or move it's always going to be there
that you want to try it and you might as
well yeah you're only going to let
yourself down otherwise yeah and i think
it's important to remember like
like i think in those moments like what
is the worst case scenario exactly let's
be honest
you can get you can become employed
again but you're going to be way more
comfortable with that decision if you
know you've given it a real crack
especially in recruitment yeah there's
so many transferable skills i think
people just forget that farming
recruiters but with sales people as well
and there's so many things that you can
go and do after recruitment if it all
goes yeah it all goes picked on and you
don't want to do anymore yeah or just go
get another recruitment job yeah because
they'll look and see okay you tried
didn't work out why scratch that itch
and then yeah yeah love that well i
really enjoyed that first year excited
to hear about the future years but thank
you so much for coming and sharing that
and really excited for everyone to
listen to that so thanks a lot thank you
cheers thanks thank you so much for
listening to the episode i hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
[Music]